how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and of
course spider-man which sometimes is not
the mcu if we're talking about venom or
morbius or etc but spider-man no way
home got everybody super excited for the
future of what's to come after no way
home after spider-man no way home
seemingly did the impossible bringing
all three generations of spider-man
together on screen a lot of fans are
wondering well what's next how could
they top the three spider-man being on
screen well in this video we're going to
talk about all upcoming spider-man
projects from marvel disney and sony
ones that are confirmed to be coming and
ones that are just kind of rumors right
now but we really really hope we get
this is everything from spider-man 4
with tom holland to the amazing
spider-man 3 with andrew garfield to a
spider woman movie that is coming and
then hopefully a miles morales movie so
we'll talk about all this and a lot more
in this video and if you're new be sure
to subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the latest videos now i want to
clarify something about spider-man 4 the
next tom holland spider-man movie
because there seems to be a lot of
confusion lately because tom holland is
really kind of playing coy if he's going
to be returning or not and the short
answer to this is yes he is going to be
returning as spider-man tom holland has
come a pretty long way since we deemed
him spoiler man and he started spoiling
everything about upcoming movies now
he's pretty much a safe he didn't let
anything out about spider-man no way
home and it seems like he's doing the
same thing keeping his mouth shut about
spider-man 4. fortunately for us kevin
feige president of marvel studios and
amy pascale executive producer at sony
have confirmed they are actively working
on a spider-man 4 right now and they did
say that the ending of spider-man no way
home is where they are picking up with
the story so it is going to be tom
holland spider-man in an interview with
the new york times kevin feige said amy
and i and disney and sony are talking
about yes we're actively beginning to
develop where the story heads next which
i only say outright because i don't want
fans to go through any separation trauma
like what happened after far from home
that of course was when we were
wondering if spider-man was going to
remain in the mcu or not when sony and
disney were kind of working out a new
agreement so the first movie we will
confirm is spider-man 4 with tom holland
it is definitely happening now it's a
few years away of course and hopefully
they do another trilogy and do
spider-man 5 and spider-man 6. but right
now we're really excited to be getting a
spider-man 4. now the next big one that
a lot of people are talking about right
now which isn't confirmed is the amazing
spider-man 3. after spider-man no way
home fans are signing petitions to get
andrew garfield and sony to make the
amazing spider-man 3 after his
performance in no way home which was
fantastic in fact even today tom holland
in an interview with the phase zero
podcast said that he fully supports the
making of the amazing spider-man 3 with
andrew garfield and would love to see it
rumors are that it's being talked about
at the studio right now but of course
it's not confirmed but fingers crossed
for this one because i'd really love to
see it now of course we have movies that
are already confirmed like morbius
presuming it actually ever comes out and
doesn't just keep getting delayed right
now it's scheduled to be coming out on
april 1st april fool's day of this year
then we have across the spiderverse part
1 and then of course part 2 which they
will be making the first one right now
is scheduled to come out on october 7th
of this year and the next one in 2023
now recently today we got a confirmation
for another spider-man based film coming
to sony in fact they have now cast
madame webb or at least have their front
runner for the film in a report today by
variety.com they say that dakota johnson
is suiting up for the sony universe of
marvel characters and has been cast as
madame webb they do say it's not a done
deal but she is in final talks to close
the deal to play madame webb in sony's
first female-led spider-man movie and i
have to say that this movie should be
rather interesting because if they do it
the right way this could keep the
spider-verse around for a very very long
time and give us a lot of explanations
on how it actually works due to her
close ties to the web of life and
destiny so hopefully this movie is as
good as it could be now another
confirmed movie that we have coming up
is craven the hunter sony has cast aaron
taylor johnson to play craven the hunter
and we think we might see spider-man in
the film after all he is a very big
spider-man villain so it would make
sense that spider-man would show up at
some point in the film now would
spider-man could this be we're not
really sure maybe it's andrew maybe it's
tom we'll have to wait and see now
speaking of spider-man venom 3 is also
confirmed to be coming as well and tom
hardy has expressed that he wants it to
be a spider-man vs venom film however at
this point in time it doesn't look like
he's going to be going up against tom
holland spider-man but a different
spider-man which we're all thinking is
probably going to be andrew garfield
we'll have to wait and see on that one
but venom 3 is confirmed and tom hardy
said he's going to do everything in his
power to make it a venom vs spider-man
film another confirmed movie that we
have coming is what we believe to be a
spider woman movie directed by olivia
wilde the project is confirmed and
olivia wilde is confirmed to be
directing the project although they
haven't specifically revealed what it is
rumors have it that it's going to be a
spider woman film and will follow the
story of jessica drew and again if this
is done right and olivia wilde has
directed a lot of great movies recently
it could be a phenomenal movie then we
have a sinister six movie which has been
confirmed to be in the works by sony for
a very long time now it was back in 2018
that sony producer amy pasquel said that
they are working on a sinister six film
in 2018 amy pasquel said that it is
still in the works but she's waiting for
director drew goddard to be ready to
direct it because he also wrote the
script for it now as of right now this
movie is still in the works and hasn't
been cancelled and since they had
spider-man no way home on their plate
i'm assuming that took most of their
time especially since they were doing
across the spider-verse morbius and
venom as well so hopefully a true
sinister six movie gets going because
you know that has to have a spider-man
in it you can't really do a sinister six
film without spider-man in it and again
the question is which one and to top
this off with the rumored list and the
speculated list i think are two of the
most exciting projects that we could
possibly get one is spider-gwen in the
exploration of the multiverse there is a
universe out there where gwen doesn't
die but is indeed spider gwen and right
now rumors are going around that sony is
looking to develop a spider gwen film
and this would be an awesome film spider
gwen is a fan favorite including a
favorite of mine and i would really like
emma stone to come back however i'm not
sure they will go that route that might
lead to a little bit of confusion since
she died however they just did spiderman
no way home with a lot of characters
that died and they pulled it off so
fingers crossed that sony actually goes
through with this and last but not least
is a movie that we are going to be
getting we just don't know when and that
is a miles morales movie now i will say
what is most likely going to happen is
that spider-man with tom holland will
get four five and six three more
spider-man films with tom holland in
which they will probably introduce miles
morales in one of these films spider-man
homecoming confirmed that miles morales
does exist in the mcu as we met his
uncle prowler who said he has a nephew
so miles does exist and hopefully he
gets introduced in one of the upcoming
spider-man mcu films and then tom
holland's peter parker can mentor him
eventually leading up to tom holland
spider-man saying goodbye and miles
morales becoming the new spider-man of
the mcu it's been rumored that marvel
has been wanting to bring in miles
morales for some time now which is
obviously why they put him in spider-man
no way home or at least a reference of
him and it's only a matter of time at
this point until he shows up
unfortunately we might have to wait many
years until he gets his own film but on
the fortunate side he'll probably be
introduced before then and it'll be
really cool to see him fight alongside
tom holland's peter parker so right now
those are the big spider-man universe
movies coming up let me know which one
you are most excited about in the
comments down below i think i would
really really really be excited if they
made tasm 3. but leave your favorite
down below don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you don't miss
out on any future videos for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof